aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
quelqu'un qui a fait croire à une
famille qu'il était leur fils qui
revenait de voyage il a fait croire ça
un village entier l'histoire allait
incroyable il a volé la vie d'une
personne et personne ne se rende compte
de rien oh vous l'avez compris c'est le
deuxième épisode de ce nouveau format je
sais toujours pas comment vous avez
accueilli le premier épisode parce que
je tourne l'été peut les deux épisodes à
la foulée c'est pour ça que je sais
vraiment pas brillé en un mois la barbe
a pas poussé les vêtements pas changé
parce que je je tournais deux en même
temps bon on est clairement sur la plus
grosse usurpation d'identité de toute
l'histoire c'est fascinant alexandre
dumas en a même fait un récit qui a été
adapté en film les gens en ont beaucoup
parlé une époque beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être
découvrir cette histoire c'est
l'histoire de martin guerre mais
personne n'a relevé un point de détail
on peut tromper beaucoup de personnes sa
famille ses amis tout son village mais
pas son conjoint ou sa conjointe cette
personne là elle est obligée de s'en
rendre compte et vous allez voir que
c'est un détail extrêmement important
quand on le prend en compte parce que un
jour un homme a décidé de vivre un
mensonge pour toujours celui d'être
quelqu'un qui s'appelle martin guerre
quelqu'un qui était parti il a pris sa
place et sa femme l'a forcément
découvert et là forcément partager tout
ce mensonge toute sa vie avec lui
[Musique]
martin guerre il est né au mois de
janvier le 10 janvier 1539 du côté de
toulouse il a été mariée très jeune ça
se faisait à l'époque là je crois que
lui c'est maria 11 ans et sa femme à la
vie de 10 ans dans le sud ouest en
15/100 ça se fait même si c'est un peu
délicat parce que ça va contre le but
même du mariage l'époque à savoir la
procréation peuvent pas avoir d'enfant
donc ya pas tellement d'intérêt à marier
les enfants entre eux aujourd'hui ça
nous paraît horrible de voir ça mais je
vous replace dans le contexte de
l'époque alors martin guerre il été
élevé par son oncle bière guerre et il
est possible aussi qu'à l'époque pierre
guerre et payer le curé pour que le
marriage is fasse sans problèmes parce
que pierre guerre c'était
de notoriété publique que c'était un
gros radin et donc si marié 111 109 e
son neveu et sa femme devait s'assumer
donc ça faisait une bouche de moins à
nourrir et en plus de ça il récupérer
quand même la dot de la mariée ce qui
pourrait être intéressant pour lui donc
ce très jeune martin est marié à sa très
jeune femme qui s'appelle bertrand
prénom de l'époque une dizaine d'années
passent et il ya bien détails sur martin
guerre c'est qu'il est il est plutôt
chaud en fait les pas très beau il ya
des cicatrices sur tout le corps à cause
d'une maladie pau qui l'a et surtout le
mariage est pas consommer il a jamais
été consommé tiens c'est pas qu'ils ont
pas eu d'enfant c'est que il n'a pas
fait ce qu'il faut pour essayer d'avoir
un enfant et on le sait parce que sa
femme bertrande est allé voir le curé
pour lui demander des conseils alors pas
pour essayer de faire des enfants je
pense que elle savait mais au contraire
pour demander le divorce parce que c'est
la seule raison si le mariage est pas
consommer c'est la seule raison qui a
accepté par l'église pour annuler un
divorce si le mariage a pas été consommé
alors elle peut demander le divorce mais
coup de théâtre
bertrande tombe enceinte et c'est là on
commence à se dire et donc eu bertrande
à serait pas allé voir d'autres
personnes que martin dans le village
c'est quand même bizarre qu'elle se
plaignent de partout que le mariage ait
pas été consommés qu'elles demandent
conseil au curé puis du jour au
lendemain ou alors elle tombe enceinte
donc elle se traîne une très mauvaise
réputation mais pas très longtemps parce
qu'on se rend compte que martin guerre
est devenu super volage qui la trompe
avec énormément de personnes qui
déraille à tort et à travers en
permanence ce qui d'ailleurs occasionne
des grandes engueulade avec son épouse
avec bertrand qui fait euros c'est en
fait c'est pas bien ce que tu fais dont
une qui est plus sévère que les autres
et à l'issue de cette embrouille martin
fait son baluchon il part en direction
de toulouse et un jour passent une
semaine un mois deux mois trois mois
toujours pas de martin guerre à
l'horizon donc bertrand de elle se
débrouille elle reste fidèle à un martin
à son mariage il se passe rien à la une
fille plutôt pieuse et une vie plutôt
dur aussi plus rudes puisqu'elle doit
subvenir dans seul à ses besoins et
c'est donc s'occuper de ce qu'elle avait
ça on y reviendra jusqu'à ce que huit
ans plus tard il ya un homme qui marche
sur l'entrée du village et il ya des
paysans qui sont en train de travailler
qui relève la tête et ils font partie
c'est martin c'est martin guerre qui
revient 1 et martin météo martin et tout
le monde rapplique et accueille martin
guerre qui est revenu de on ne sait pas
où au bout de huit ans d'absence vers le
mec il a pris son baluchon vas tu me
saoules tu avais qu ils rigolent pas
quoi quand il dit tu me saoules je vais
faire un tour 8 encore là c'est une
question il dit qu'il s'est enrôlé dans
l'armée qui des partis faire la guerre
dans le nord qu'il a tenu le siège de
saint quentin il par beaucoup ils
racontent toute son histoire y parle
énormément au point qu'il ya des hommes
du village qui qui qui sont un peu
étonnés parce qu'ils y but d'un martin
il était pas il n'était pas bavard avant
c'était plutôt un timide un taiseux élus
en font paris disait bien que tu parles
beaucoup toi par rapport à vent et
martin d'iweb la guerre ça change un
homme donc aller faire la guerre allait
tenir un siège et après on voit comment
vous vous revenez c'est plutôt accepté
par tout le monde il quitte le groupe de
paysans et il va directement vers sa
maison c'est important de dire
directement parce qu'ils se trompent pas
de chemin il cherche pas sa maison il
retrouve femmes et enfants sa femme et
son fils pareil qui le reconnaissent
tous enfin je veux dire y'a pas de
problème ya une seule petite différence
c'est que quand on lui parle basque il
comprend plus tout le monde est très
étonné de ça parce que martin guerre par
les comprenait très bien le basque
depuis sa naissance et du coup il
explique que perdu en picardie pendant
la guerre ça lui a fait oublié sa langue
natale c'est le seul petit point qui
diffère entre quand il est parti quand
il est rentré bertrand en tout cas sa
femme à l'air très heureuse de l'avoir
trouvée tellement heureuse que le couple
va se retrouver que neuf mois après son
retour elle donne naissance à un nouveau
bébé une petite fille tout le monde est
très heureux en faisant martin est
l'heureux bertrand des heureux le
village est heureux en fait il ya juste
une personne dans le village qui est pas
très heureuse c'est pierre guerre vous
souvenez c'est l'oncle aux gradins de
martin guerre il tient un peu la gueule
évidemment pierre guerre veut voir le
martin qui est de retour donc martin y
va ils boivent ensemble ils mangent
ensemble ça papote ça se raconte des
souvenirs ensemble des souvenirs
d'enfance en plus soit une heure quand
je te faisais ça petit oui j'avais 8 ans
je m'en souviens et où tout est très
cohérent en plus vous lire il ya aucun
problème il est il et il est incollable
martin n'y a pas de problème sur ses
propres souvenirs et puis la
conversation commencent à s'envenimer un
petit peu quand on martin dit du coup en
mon absence c'est toi qui a exploité
toutes mes terres en fête 1 tu as fait
ton temps paysans sur terre et sur mes
terres et donc sont donc le dubawi bon
si occupés coffret même quelques raisons
occupe donc martin lui dit d'accord du
coup tu vas me rendre l'argent que tu as
gagné grâce à l'exploitation de mes
propres terres peut-être pas tout mais
tu vas me donner un bon paquet de fric
là dessus parce que le pearson a donné
l'autorisation et toi t'as fait ça comme
ça évidemment l'oncle carabins de base
dit non non c'est hors de question c'est
moi qui exploite et je me suis levé le
matin j'ai travaillé ça me faisait
double de travail avec mes terres on
savait même pas si si si tu allais
rentrée où tu étais si tu étais mort
donc c'est hors de question martin lâche
pas la faire lui colle un procès il
gagne le procès et pierre guerre est
condamné à lui verser 3200 livre
n'aurait peut-être pas dû faire ça
martin guerre s'attaquer à l'argent
d'arad 1 quand on n'est pas tout à fait
clean dans ce qu'on fait est dans ce
qu'on dit c'est pas la meilleure idée qu
il est l'oncle réfléchissent dit mais
attends monde veut sa jamais été un gros
malin n'était pas courageux étaient même
plutôt lâche en fait il tremblait devant
moi il avait peur de moi quand je
parlais
quand il était petit il ya huit ans
également avant qu'ils partent à la
guerre je veux bien qu'il ait fait la
guerre mais la guerre ça rend pas plus
intelligent peut-être ça rend plus
courageux ou en tout cas plus
inconscient mais en tout cas ça rend pas
plus malin il commence à apercevoir des
différences de comportement le fait
qu'ils parlent le plus qui n'ai pas peur
de lui qui parle plus basque etc c'est
commence à lui paraître bien suspect
pour lui c'est sûr la personne qui est
venu lui coller un procès c'est pas
martin guerre il veut pas payer les 3200
livres et compte bien ne pas les payer
en prouvant que c'est un imposteur et
que c'est quelqu'un qui se fait passer
pour son neveu il fait sa petite enquête
l'oncle dans le village qui s'appelle
artiga et tout le monde jure avoir
reconnu martin et surtout c'est ça qui
est troublant tout le monde raconte
partager des souvenirs avec lui et qu'
il n'y a pas de bug quoi il se souvient
d'être hué qui complète il parle des
années de ce qui s'est passé et c'est
donc aucune raison de douter il ya que
lui qui doute en fait alors l'oncle
élargi un petit peu l'enquète il va dans
les villages alentour il va de plus en
plus loin mais à un moment donné dans
une auberge il rencontre un soldat qu'il
entend parler de martin guerre et qui
lui dit quoi martin guerre est rentré
chez lui non ça ce matin ne laissent pas
possible parce que il est toujours dans
le nord moi je le connais on a fait la
guerre ensemble on appelle siège de
saint quentin il est resté dans le nord
parce qu'il a rencontré quelqu'un il
habite là-bas et tout mais je voudrais
pas rentrer parce qu'il a une jambe de
bois maintenant tout serait trop
compliqué pour lui direct l'oncle il
retourne à artigat il va frapper
directement chez martin la porte s'ouvre
et continue à frapper donc pas sur la
porte mais sur le visage de martin ont
ajouté qu'un imposteur et star il savait
vraiment il ya une grosse bagarre entre
deux entre les deux galas qui
s'enclenche à ce moment là et c'est
bertrand qui va les séparer et qui va
stopper en disant cette phrase précise
qui mieux que moi peut savoir que c'est
martin quand même et donc sa coupe court
au combat surtout que son argument de
choc qui mieux que moi peut savoir ça
fait mouche c'est à dire que tout
village est plutôt d'accord avec elle
déjà pour eux c'était martin n'est pas
de souci ils ont entendu les les
arguments de l'oncle zizou il me bon
encontre et un soldat qui compte et
n'importe quoi parce qu'évidemment si
c'était pas martin bertrand da le sort
et est donc la pierre guerre arrête son
enquête
c'est faux bien sûr qui va continuer
c'est un radin il ne veut pas payer tous
qui continue son enquête et dans un
autre village n'est pas très loin
d'artigat en définitif c'est le village
de s'agace il découvre mais c'est
vraiment un pur hasard qu'en fait martin
il ressemble vachement un gars de là bas
et que ce gars de là bas il s'appelle
arnaud dutil et c'est un mec il ya eu
énormément de problèmes d'escroquerie
des deux petites magouilles du coup de
problèmes avec la justice ils se
ressemblent comme deux gouttes d'eau
mais l'un ressemble déjà pas mal à
l'autre il est fort possible pour
l'oncle de martin que ce soit arnaud
dutil qu'ils soient revenus artiga en se
faisant passer directement pour martin
guerre c'est ce qui paraît le plus
plausible en tout cas l'ongle va prêcher
le faux pour savoir le vrai il va aller
à la rencontre de bertrand un soir où
aller tout seul il va discuter avec elle
en lui mettant des gros coup de pression
en mode je sais que c'est pas martin je
sais que tu sais que c'est pas martin et
que c'est arnaud dutil est en fait tu
toi tu que tu es en train de faire là on
vivre avec lui c'est que tu es en train
de vivre dans le péché donc tu va périr
en enfer ton âme sera d'année à tout
jamais si tu ne changent pas de
comportement maintenant il ça ça marche
énormément sur bertrand tca des très
fortes croyances religieuses et
intérieurement elle s'est dit et c'est
pas bon à ce qui se passe pour moi donc
il lui met un vrai coup de pression
comme ça qui a l'air plutôt de
fonctionner en vase ou même faxée à
lattes fonctionner sais c'est que ça
fonctionne puisque l'oncle de martin
dépose une plainte avec la femme de
martin au tribunal pour usurpation
d'identité
martin guerre et amenés au tribunal le
jour j le juge lui pose énormément de
questions sur sa vie sur son enfant sur
des détails même parfois intimes et c
est le le le potentiel faux martin
guerre répond juste à tout mais vraiment
étonnamment quoi c'est très précis il ya
retenir qui le colle il sait tout sur
tout et une fois qu'il a répondu à
toutes les questions
lui qui prend la parole martin guay à
produire s'cusez moi mais moi je veux
bien répondre à vos questions mais si
j'étais pas martin guerre pourquoi ma
femme alors est attendu deux ans pour
porter plainte pourquoi mon oncle aurait
dit m'avoir reconnu et pourquoi il
aurait attendu lui aussi deux ans pour
porter plein de belles je vais vous le
dire parce que mon oncle manipule ma
femme il a monté une machination avec
elle pour ne pas me rendre les 3200
livre qu'il me doit c'est pour ça parce
qu'il est trop radin et ça marche ça
marche parce que maintenant le juge alt
doute alors il décide de faire venir 150
personnes des villages alentours les 150
personnes des deux villages de s'agacer
d'artigat reconnaissent formellement la
personne qui est à la barre j'irai aussi
marrante c'est parce que en fait sur les
150 personnes y en a 40 d'artigat et ses
40 la disent pas c'est bien martin
guerre il y en a cent dix du village
voisin qui disent vouloir le reconnaît
c'est arnaud dutil donc on n'est sûr de
rien on est sûr d'une seule chose c'est
que les deux en fait son sosie au final
mais maintenant il reste juste à savoir
qui est qui est ce que c'est le vrai
martin guerre ou est-ce que serrano
dutil parts un gars en profitera pour
eux pour faire une concession dans son
discours au tribunal il va dire c'est
vrai que j'ai menti et je croyais que
c'était pour ça que j'ai été appelé à la
barre c'est vrai que j'ai menti sur un
point quand j'étais à la guerre je me
suis pas enrôlés dans les troupes du roi
de france mais je me suis enrôlé dans
les troupes du roi d'espagne pour
diverses raisons voilà c'est le seul
point sur lequel j'avais menti depuis le
départ pendant qu'il fait ce témoignage
là on a retrouvé l'oncle d'arnaud dutil
et on le fait venir à la barre l'oncle
d'arnaud reconnaît son neveu donc
arnauduc il est là martin guerre dit
c'est un fou c'est un menteur je pense
qu'il a été payé par mon oncle pour
faussement reconnaître son neveu et me
mettre dans la panade encore une fois
tout ça c'est une histoire de
machination montée par mon donc pour ne
pas payer ce qui ne doit juste avant que
le jugement soit rendu un dernier
témoignage est quand même troublant
c'est le cordonnier du village d'artigat
donc le village où habite martin guerre
qui dit moi j'ai juste un truc qui est
un petit peu bizarre un peu chelou
bertrand des venues commandes et des
chaussures pour
pour martin est à l'abri en taille 9
alors que avant que martin partent à la
guerre va peser du 12 donc ça m'a paru
bizarre quand même qu'ils perdent trois
tailles ce témoignage là il est fort les
compromettants ça tape très fort sur le
doute c'est à dire que et oui sur un
truc aussi bête que la pointure on peut
savoir qui est qui donc martin se prend
une bonne peine de l'époque il est
reconnu coupable d'usurpation d'identité
et potentiellement d'escroquerie il est
condamné à la décapitation avec
déchirement du corps en quatre morceaux
exposition des quatre morceaux de son
corps aux quatre coins de la ville ouais
c'est vraiment les les sentences de
l'époque c'est pas des travaux
d'intérêts généraux c'est plutôt un truc
de comme ça ça va bien passer en bio aux
autres d'aller au tribunal évidemment
martin est pas fou vous l'avez compris
c'est un homme malin donc il fait appel
il va au parlement de toulouse pour ça
il fait appel de sa condamnation s'est
pris en compte un nouveau jugement est
lancé on fait venir 25 personnes sur les
25 y en a dix qui reconnaissent martin 8
qui reconnaissent arnaud dutil et 7 qui
disent bah en fait je sais pas je ne
sais pas différencier mais c'est pas le
même poids qu'au premier procès parce
que l'oncle d'arnaud dutil est décédé
entre temps et le cordonnier quand il
revient à la barre comme monde on lui
met la pression dans le dire mais vous
êtes sûrs pour les tailles de chaussures
il commence à paniquer et à dire mais je
suis sûr de rien il me semblait que
après peut-être que je me suis trompé
avec un autre gars j'ai pas de notes de
ça donc non je suis pas sûr la dernière
personne interrogée lors de cet appel
c'est la femme de martin c'est bertrande
et pendant qu'elle est à la barre martin
se lève et dire j'adjure ma femme ici
présentes bertrande de me regarder droit
dans les yeux et deux jurés au nom du
christ au nom du seigneur que je ne suis
pas son mari et que je suis un imposteur
à ça bertrand qui était déjà un petit
peu flipper à une montée d'émotion elle
vacille elle tombe dans les pommes avec
des larmes qui coulent etc et tout le
monde prend ça quand même pour une
preuve que c'est bien martin que malgré
tout elle n'est pas capable de jurer que
ça c'est pas son mari c'est un imposteur
donc qu'elle s'est peut-être fait
manipuler par l'oncle en tout cas tout
le monde prend ça pour de la bonne foi
du fait que c'est martin il est acquitté
reconnu comme étant martin guerre il
rentre au village est vraiment tout va
bien du coup ça va pour lui ça va pour
bertrande tout le village a oublié cette
histoire pour eux c'est bien martin tout
va bien il n'y a aucun souci tout le
monde est heureux
sauf qu'ils arguèrent parce qu'alors
pierre guerre l'oncle de martin doit
toujours payer les 3200 livre mais en
plus
un seul terrible il doit payer tous les
frais de justice qu'on étende engendrés
par les deux procès qui l'a initié et
qu'il a perdu il salue va pas tellement
en fait à pierre guerre du coup il
change son fusil d'épaulé plutôt que de
faire reconnaître que le martin guerre
qu'elle a n'est pas le vrai martin
guerre il part du village et il va
commencer à faire une enquête pour
retrouver le vrai martin guerre et le
ramener au village il dit si je peux pas
prouver que oui il faut ben alors dans
ces cas là je ramène le vrai et ça
prouve automatiquement que l'autre est
faux il a la rage le pierre guerre ils
le trouvent au final en espagne il dira
jamais où est ce qu'il a trouvé mais ils
le trouvent en espagne là effectivement
une jambe de bois il le ramène au
village et quand ils le ramènent au
village sa soeur la soeur de martin
guerre se jette à son cou en mode mon
frère quoi y'a rien n'a changé à part la
jambe de bois mais là c'est sûr et
certain pour tout le monde c'est bien
lui le vrai martin guerre c'est celui
qui viendront bien bertrande elle le
voit direct avec tombe dans les pommes
elle se réveille et elle dit oh la la
c'est bien toi tu m'as abuser et ce à
quoi martin guerre aurait répondu mon
oncle et ma soeur ont pu être abusés
mais pas toi tu m'as forcément déshonoré
résultat le martin guerre qui était et
qui était là depuis le départ
le potentiellement faux martin guerre
est arrêté et on repart pour un procès
et alors là où les brillants sega c'est
qu'au procès il dit non mais en fait mon
oncle qui veut toujours femmes payées
qui veut toujours pas payé tous qui doit
payer pour les deux procès qu'il a perdu
il est parti en espagne on ne sait pas
combien de temps ou ne sais même pas où
puisqu'il avait dit pour chercher un mec
qui me ressemble un sosie et ramènent un
sosie pour faire croire que ce serait le
vrai martin guerre mais c'est moi le
vrai martin guerre le mec a bien juste
de ramener un sosie puis c'est tout
c'est pas con comme défense et là il se
passe un délire on met en confrontation
les deux martin donc le martin qui est
revenu là qui fait tout les procédures
le martin qu'à la jambe de bois qu'on a
été chercher en espagne et on les fait
jouer au jeu de qui connaît le mieux la
vie de martin guerre donc on pose des
questions aux deux et les deux se pose
des questions l'un à l'autre et ce qui
est amusant c'est qu'il y en a un qui
répondent rapidement précisément avec
plein de détails c'est le martin guerre
qui accusé d'être un faux et l'autre
celui qui a une jambe de bois bay bredou
il hésite et ils seront dans ses
réponses et caetera et donc à la fin le
martin calais dans les jambes fait vous
voyez bien il sait pas il connaît pas la
réponse c'est un sosie qui a été
chercher par mon oncle et pourquoi même
ce serait pas arnaud dutil le mec qu'on
m'accuse d'être que mon oncle aurait
trouvé en espagne puisque mon ongle
savez carnot dutil me ressemblait en
fait il est allé chercher arnaud dutil
il a ramené pour faire croire qu arnaud
dutil et martin guerre et qu'on fasse
croire à tout le monde que moi je suis
arnaud dutil 1 j'ai compris ça paraît
compliqué portance et une bonne défense
en tout cas ça sème assez le doute pour
qui un nouveau procès à toulouse on est
déjà au quatrième procès sans déconner
là par contre il procéderait pas se
passer très vite parce que 100 % des
habitants disent que le mec qui revenue
avec la jambe de bois c'est martin
guerre c'est à dire que tout ce qu'ont
connu martin dans le passé quand tu mets
les deux à côté celui qui vient de
revenir avec sa jambe de bois et celui
qui se fait passer pour martin guerre
depuis des années pour eux c'est très
clair c'est celui avec la jambe de bois
c'est le vrai martin guerre la ja puis
quand ils le voient ya pas de doute donc
le faux martin guerre en réalité qui est
bien arnaud dutil est enfermé et il est
condamné à passer la potence alors c'est
pas une hypothèse que ce soir nos dutil
une fois qu'il a été condamné enfermé et
qui savait qu'il allait être pendus il a
confié en fait tout ça et même comment
il avait fait je vais pouvoir vous le
raconter maintenant donc en cellule et
dit au juge peu volage qu'un appert donc
oui je peux je peux vous expliquer tout
ça n'était pas du tout prémédité arnaud
explique qu'il était dans la même armée
le martin guerre l'armée espagnole et
que comme a effectivement il se
ressembler physiquement l'un l'autre ça
les a rapprochés ils ont sympathisé à
force que les gens les confondre ils
sont devenus poteau à cause de ça donc
ils partageaient tout leur temps de
guerre ensemble et martin passé son
temps à raconter sa vie arnaud dutil
parce qu'ils se plaignaient en fatis il
expliqué pourquoi il était parti de chez
lui comment sa femme l'avait sous les
commençons donc lille et airolo avec lui
il parlait très mal des gens de son
village il raconter tout ça ce toutes
ces histoires en permanence en eau dutil
avait rien demandé et ils veulent pas
tirer les vers du nez pour que lee
raconte ses souvenirs c'est juste martin
qui en voulait un peu à la terre entière
et à son village et à sa femme et à son
oncle qui parlait tout le temps de sa
vie à la fin du siège de saint quentin à
la fin de la guerre arnaud dutil voulais
juste rentrer à sa glace et comme ils
rentraient à pied damman il passe par
les villages et il traverse le village
d'artigat qu'il était obligé de
traverser pour entrer à s'agace et
pendant qu'ils marchent sur le chemin
c'est là rappelez vous du début de
l'histoire qu'un paysan qui était en
train de travailler la terre relève la
tête et commence à dire c'est martin
guerre c'est martin martin est revenu et
tout le monde commence à dire martin est
revenu martin est revenu et arnaud se
demande ce qui se passait il comprend
doutiez disais mais oui en fait comme je
ressemble c'est vrai que les dés de ce
village ils sont en train de me prendre
pour lui et chez lui arnaud dutil dans
son village il est considéré comme un
vaurien un escroc je vous rappelle il
avait des problèmes avec la justice et
ses
bas il se dit
j'ai rien à perdre on n'a qu'à faire ça
en fait et c'est là c'est à ce moment là
qu'il commence vraiment à se faire
passer pour matin guerre en plus il est
nourri de tous les souvenirs qu'il a des
conversations de tous que le racontait
martin quand l'ex plaignait de sa vie
donc donc il savait où était la maison
il connaît le nom de sa famille
connaissait assez de souvenirs en tout
cas pour pour faire la farce il a assuré
d'ailleurs au tribunal que sa femme ne
savait rien vous n'avez jamais compris
et ne savait rien du tout sur le fait
qu'il était arnaud dutil et par mme
martin guerre et c'est juste là que le
bât blesse l'histoire à la base elle se
termine comme ça mais c'est pas possible
car les pas compris que c'est un martin
guerre je vous ai expliqué pourquoi
parce que martin il a raconté comme ça
quelques bribes de son passé arnaud
dutil quand il était à larmes mais c'est
pas assez pour se faire passer pour
martin guerre pour toujours c'est pas
assez pour résister au tribunal aux
questions qu'on lui pose aux souvenirs
d'enfance que lui parc son oncle c'est
pas des souvenirs que martin aurait plus
raconté il n'a pas non plus raconté
toute son histoire à tort et à travers
la seule possibilité qu'il ait eu pour
ce faire passer aussi longtemps pour
martin guerre c'est que bertrande elles
soient au courant dès le départ tous
potentiellement et je pense c'est
probablement le cas elle soit tombée
amoureuse de ce nouveau martin d'arnaud
dutil et que du coup elle les briefer
sur tout ce qui lui manquait il ya lui
elle fait la leçon pour lui apprendre
tous les souvenirs de martin guerre et
elle a les connais tous les souvenirs de
martin puisque je vous rappelle ils sont
mariés à 10 ans et 11 ans donc elle
connaît toute sa vie passée au village
il a pu réussir ce tour de force que si
bertrand lui a appris tout ce qu'il
avait à savoir pour moi elle était
forcément amoureuse et c'était forcément
un vrai couple ce qui est dommage dans
cette histoire c'est que sans porter des
jugements de valeur comme ça vite fait
c'est que c'est que martin guerre ma foi
il l'aimé pas trop son village sa femme
sont donc et c'est quoi et arnaud dutil
a priori était heureux avec bertrand
lisez les choses bien et tout donc ça
tout ça toute cette histoire qui aurait
pu être heureuse et arrangé un petit peu
tout le monde au final elle s'écroule et
brunes chose un oncle rade parce qu'à un
moment donné il a voulu récupérer de
l'argent de l'exploitation des terres
qui étaient pas à lui au départ et qu'il
n'a pas voulu lâcher la faire vêler
tombé sur un mec assez radin pour
découvrir le pot-aux-roses et surtout ne
pas lâcher la faire jusqu'au bout voilà
pourquoi pour moi c'est la plus grande
usurpation d'identité de l'histoire au
moins une des plus grandes et c'est la
fin de ce deuxième format 2 très
d'horreur qui n'ont rien d'orifices qui
sont plutôt des histoires bellemare
j'espère que celui ci aussi vous aura
plus que cette histoire vous aura plu
comme pour le premier épisode hâte de
lire vos commentaires à de voir le
nombre de vues que vous allez faire
faire à cette vidéo le nombre de like de
partage parce que c'est ce qui va me
donner le signal de est ce qu'on
continue à la rentrée ou pas je vais
être très honnête j'étais en ait deux
épisodes celui que vous avez vu en
juillet celui que vous voyez ce mois ci
et c'est en voyant un peu comment on
fonctionne et les deux qu'on continuera
en faire ou pas moi je kiffe je kiffe
donc je regarderai la vidéo en boucle
voilà c'est comme ça si oui si vous
aimez les histoires un peu à la belle
marque comme cette personne je mettrai
aussi des liens dans la description si
j'y pense oui bien sûr si j'y pense
pensez à vous abonner à activer la
cloche comme d'habitude prenez soin de
vous à très bientôt
ciao